une naissance dans une toute petite
maison au fin fond de l'ardèche
jusqu'à ce moment maintenant ici devant
vous j'ai tout le temps grandi dans des
jardins mais pas dans n'importe quel
jardin dans des jardins de production de
semences donc la semence
c'est vraiment le socle de nos
civilisations
c'est le socle de toute agriculture et
c'est aussi évidemment le socle de la
nature je sais pas pour vous qu'est ce
que ça fait vibrer chez vous ce mot
semences mais pour moi en fait ça
signifie la vie plus que la fuye ça
signifie le partage est vraiment ce que
ça signifie c'est l'abondance et sata
bond ans j'ai envie de vous la montrer
avec un exemple très simple je pense que
tous ici vous avez déjà mangé de la
laitue la laitue si vous prenez une
graine de laitue et que vous la semaine
elle va elle va pousser et si vous la
laisser finir son cycle de croissance
elle va monter en graine comme sur
l'image à droite et au bout de cinq à
huit mois à peu près selon les variétés
elle va vous offrir entre cinq et dix
mille grain donc on va prendre 8000 pour
prendre une petite moyenne et on va
faire une petite expérience vous allez
prendre ces 8000 graines et les re semer
et récolter à nouveau les 8000 graines
que toutes celles et tous vont vous
offrir
et ainsi de suite jusqu'à la troisième
année et vous aurez en votre possession
512 milliards de laitue alors vous avez
de quoi recouvrir l'intégralité de la
région occitanie on les tue un peu plus
vous faites ça encore une année et là
vous pouvez recouvrir les deux amériques
et l'afrique entière vous fait ça
jusqu'à la sixième année vous avez 262
trilliard 140 4 trillions de graines de
l'étude n'ont à ce stade on est d'accord
ça veut plus rien dire mais c'est
vraiment pour insister sur cette
abondance que la nature nous offre de 1
à 6 vous avez 262 prière
cette abondance et cette vie que nous
offre la nature on a su on a su
coexister avec elle depuis à peu près un
peu plus de dix mille ans que
l'agriculture existe
en récoltant d'année en année les
meilleurs partie des récoltes et les en
les recevant l'année suivante
et c'est évidemment une très très bonne
manière pour avoir une agriculture pour
avoir des aliments qui soit adaptée aux
besoins de l'humanité mais aussi adapté
aux besoins de nos environnements besoin
de la nature
malheureusement l'industrialisation de
nos sociétés occidentales n'a pas
épargné l'agriculture bien évidemment
qui dit industrialisation dit forcément
standardisation homogénéisation et
depuis quelques décennies quand même on
a on a sélectionné les variétés pour
brider en fait cette abondance brive et
cette gratuité et formater les variétés
à ne plus offrir cette abondance on est
même allés jusqu'à créer des monstres
génétique des ogm on va les bidouiller
dans les gènes pour que les plantes tu
leur descendance pour ne plus qu'elle
puisse se reproduire et là où c'était
botaniquement compliqué de mettre des
verrous
on est allé créer des cadres juridiques
pour pouvoir breveté la vie ou breveter
des critères génétiques
donc évidemment une telle agriculture a
de nombreuses conséquences et je vais
venir mais la première conséquence est
évidemment la perte de biodiversité je
vais en reparler un peu plus tard mais
j'ai quand même envie de vous montrer un
exemple tout de suite parce que c'est
très flagrant quand la france dans les
années 60 a créé ce qu'on a appelé l'ue
peuvent l'union pour la protection des
obtentions végétales avec une poignée de
pays membres donc tout est dans le nom
donc on est d'accord avec la
mondialisation ce qui se passe à l'autre
bout de la planète se passe dans notre
salon à l'heure actuelle vous alliez en
inde et et vous marchez dans les
campagnes où vous auriez pu compter deux
cent soixante mille variétés de riz donc
c'est dans les années 60 un c'est pas
vieux 260 mille variétés de riz
aujourd'hui si vous allez dans les
campagnes indiennes vous allez trouver
une soixantaine de variétés de riz
deux cent soixante mille variétés perdu
et une mainmise quasiment totale des
industriels gagner en quelques décennies
seulement en europe
cette industrialisation de l'agriculture
elle est un peu plus ancienne elle date
des années 1800 mhz et un réel boost a
été donnée à cette industrialisation
grâce aux deux dernières guerres elles
ont été un outil fantastique pour les
industriels parce que d'un revers de la
main ces deux guerres ont balayé à la
fois le monde paysan qui cultivait sur
des très petites surfaces énormément de
biodiversité cultivée énormément
d'espèces favorisant ainsi une grande
diversité cultivé mais aussi sauvage ce
que les petites exploitations on a les
airs on a les arbres on a une grande vie
sur ces exploitations et en même temps
ces deux guerres ont permis de légitimer
un nouveau paradigme agricole
certes mensonger mais assez réaliste sur
le moment donc ce paradigme
d'industrialisation
en fait il a été vendu au peuple d'une
manière assez simple c'est que après
après guerre il a fallu nourrir en fait
les masses de population qui allaient
s'agglutiner dans les villes qui fuyait
les campagnes et en fait comment nourrir
autant de monde qui vidait les campagnes
dont qui ne produisait plus et ben on
sur industrialisant en produisant des
tomates ou des courgettes de la même
manière qu'on produit des stylos ou des
balles de tennis
on marque à ce moment là deuxième
révolution agricole et c'est de loin la
révolution la plus importante parce que
ceux qui se sont emparés en fait à cette
époque de l'agriculture ce sont les
vendeurs d'armement ce sont les vendeurs
de mort notamment avec l'aide d'un
chimiste qui a été nommé prix nobel de
la chimie monsieur haber a été le
premier à pouvoir synthétiser l'ammoniac
absolument nécessaire à de grosses
productions de bombes mais aussi
absolument nécessaire à la production
d'engrais de synthèse que nous utilisons
encore à l'heure actuelle
monsieur laberge aussi était le premier
à créer les premiers gaz de combat les
gaz chloré c'est très important de
comprendre que notre agriculture actuel
est basé sur une agriculture de mort
tout simplement c'est assez dur à
entendre mais c'est la réalité et en
quelques décennies on est passé d'une
agriculture paysanne utilisant des
semences libre
d'une agriculture en polyculture donc
avec les animaux les fruitiers etc
1 une agro-industrie avec des semences
stériles
bref des fermes et créé pour est utilisé
par l'industrie
en moins d'un siècle selon l'aïe fao on
a perdu 75 % de la biodiversité cultivée
à tout jamais encore un exemple assez
marquant combien est-ce que vous
connaissez de variétés de tomates on va
dire une dizaine ou une quinzaine peut
être un peu plus parce que c'est devenu
assez à la mode les tomates
ce sont plus de 12 mille cinq cents
variétés tomates qui ont été répertoriés
sur la planète à l'heure actuelle et
chaque second nous ont produit quatre
mille kilos de tomates
chaque seconde et ses tomates sont issus
d'à peine 500 variétés tout hybrides f1
dont tout des clones quasiment
strictement identique au début de
l'agriculture
notre bol alimentaire était composé de
plus de 4000 espèces à l'heure actuelle
on dépasse à peine la vingtaine qu'on a
vraiment perdu une grosse masse de
biodiversité est avant tout cette
agriculture industrielle elle met en
place des systèmes de désertification
totalement dramatique et chaque seconde
ce sont 2000 400 tonnes de soles qui
sont érodés à tout jamais chaque seconde
l'équivalent de 60 semi remorque et
c'est assez logique en fait parce que
quand on produit un kilo de tomates par
exemple ou un kilo de courgettes
on gaspille entre 6 et 18 kilos de sol
et on parle ici que de matière qui
disparaît on parle pas de la vie des
sols de la faune de la microfaune des
mycélium des minéraux et de tout ce qui
tout ce qu'ils disparaissent ou sous
cette agriculture industrielle et pour
prendre un exemple encore assez flagrant
est ce que vous savez quel est l'animal
qui représente la plus grosse biomasse
de par sa présence sur la planète
ce que vous avez une idée c'est un
laboureur un aérateur un percolateur est
infertile isère de sol et c'est
évidemment le ver de terre qui
représente 80 % de la biomasse animal
avec plus de 6000 espèces
et pour cause dans un sol vivant
vraiment vivant avec toute la vie qu'un
seul doit avoir on va trouver par mètre
carré
350 à 400 individus donc une tonne à 3
tonnes par hectare qui vont creuser plus
de 5000 kilomètres de galeries donc
l'eau va s'écouler les nutriments vont
s'écouler le sol va être aéré yves êtres
vivants grâce à ces vers de terre dans
un seul mort vous aurez entre un et
quatre individus par mètre carré soit
400 fois moins dans le meilleur des cas
et évidemment l'aération du sol sa
capacité de rétention d'eau de rétention
de nutriments sa fertilité va être
largement amoindries et les processus de
désertification évidemment totalement
accéléré et on peut pas parler de
désertification
sans parler de l'eau 75% de notre
ressource eau douce sur la planète est
consommée par l'agriculture est-ce que
vous avez une idée du nombre litres
d'eau nécessaires pour produire un kilo
de viande rouge en france 13 1500 litres
et c'est très peu aux etats unis l'étude
du professeur pimentel estime entre 70
et 100 mille litres pour un kg de viande
rouge
en france on consomme en moyenne 25 kg
de viande rouge par an par personne soit
350 mille litres d'eau vous pouvez
laisser couler le robinet à fond pendant
20 jours et 28 non-stop
avant d'arriver à ce quota d'eau en fait
pour résumer un français carnivores
consomme 8 1250 litres d'eau par jour là
où un français végétarien en consomme
3600 mais dans les deux cas c'est
largement largement trop élevé par
rapport à nos ressources d'eau
disponible sur la planète
et pour finir avec lou les 75 % de cette
eau consommée par l'agriculture sont de
toute façon
archi pollué par cette agriculture à
l'aide de biocides un biocide c'est un
désastre écologique et social tout
simplement bio ça signifie la vie
sid ça signifie la mort donc les tueurs
de vie celle en on vous avez les
pesticides les herbicides les fongicides
tout ce qui finit par sid
encore une fois c'est dans le nom et
c'est dans l'histoire de ces produits ce
sont des armes des armes que nous
utilisons à tort et à travers dans
l'agriculture les conséquences sont
tellement graves est élevé qu on n
arrive même pas à les mesurer en fait
tout simplement on a des facteurs on
voit les abeilles qui disparaissent tout
le monde a entendu parler de ça on voit
les oiseaux qui disparaissent peu à peu
la vie aquatique qui meurent mais on a
du mal vraiment à mesurer mais ce qui
est sûr c'est que la terre qu'on laisse
aux générations futures à cause de ces
produits est une terre quand même
relativement empoisonné malheureusement
de plus c'est des produits qui sont
issus des énergies fossiles et à l'heure
actuelle sur la planète pour produire
une calorie alimentaire on en consomme
10 en énergies fossiles et en plus cela
calories qu'on produit va être gaspillés
pour moitié à cause du gaspillage
alimentaire et on va utiliser d'autres
calories pour les recycler encore donc
on est dans un cercle vicieux
mais je suis pas venu aujourd'hui pour
vous dire il ya un incendie on est tous
enfermés là et on va pas pouvoir sortir
au contraire en fait il ya effectivement
un incendie et je suis là en train de
vous le dire par contre il ya aussi un
grand bac d'eau et on va pouvoir
éteindre l'incendié avec il ya plein de
l'issue de secours avec des grosses
flèches vertes partout en fait où on
peut sortir et ses issues de secours une
des issues de secours pour l'agriculture
s'appelle l'agroécologie tout simplement
c'est une agriculture en co évolution
avec la nature cette agro écologie a
déjà fait ses preuves partout sur la
planète je voyage beaucoup et on a
beaucoup de témoignages et on voit ce
qui se passe
les rendements sont plus élevés la terre
et respecter les animaux sont respectés
la santé de l'humanité est respectée
et vous avez tout un tas de techniques
qui sont englobés par cette agro
écologie et tous les projets qu'on voit
vraiment fonctionné on constate que
c'est sur des petites exploitations voir
des micros exploitation parce que
prendre soin d'une ferme d'un hectare ou
de moins d'un hectare
c'est un challenge mais c'est réalisable
on va arriver à prendre soin du sol des
écosystèmes des insectes des oiseaux d'à
peu près tout en fait c'est vraiment du
travail mais c'est faisable sur une
ferme de 1000 hectares de 2000 hectares
ou de 3000 hectares
c'est impossible c'est tout simplement
impossible donc on doit revoir notre
folie des grandeurs et revenir à des
petites exploitations pour vraiment être
en contact avec cette nature une des
premières techniques que j'ai envie de
vous montrer c'est l'agroforesterie
l'agroforesterie en plus peut même être
utilisé à grande échelle
en fait c'est assez simple c'est
utiliser les arbres pour les faire qu
evo lui et avec notre agriculture on a
un concept occidental qui s'appelle la
concurrence mais qui ne s'appliquent pas
du tout à la nature on a une fâcheuse
tendance à l'appliquer aussi à la nature
mais l'agroforesterie c'est vraiment la
preuve qu'en fait il ya une co évolution
entre deux cultures des arbres fruitiers
et un champ de sarrasin par exemple
comme ici
les armes vont aller chercher en
profondeur l'eau et vont la remontée à
disposition de la culture - aller
chercher les nutriments les minéraux
vont aider à drainer l'eau pendant les
pluies diluviennes et vont éviter
l'érosion le lessivage des sols etc avec
le mycélium les cultures et les armes
vont communiquer les armes vont se
servir d'habitat pour toute une faune
qui va réguler les entre guillemets
prédateurs des cultures et la biomasse
apportées par les armes va profiter à la
culture donc c'est vraiment un exemple
en fait d'une synergie entre deux
cultures on coupe de 1400 arbres toutes
les minutes
maintenant il faut replanter ses 2400 à
toutes les minutes en les utilisant dans
la traque et culture on a tout à y
gagner
vous avez une autre technique qui
s'appelle le maraîchage sur sol vivant
et là c'est rendre plus de matière
organique au sol qu'on en consomme
inscrire la ferme dans un cercle
vertueux avec toujours plus de vie
toujours plus de sol
évidemment les rendements
son augmenter la qualité augmente et on
utilise beaucoup moins d'eau mais on est
vraiment dans un cercle vertueux ça
paraît simple dans le concept c'est un
peu plus dur à mettre en pratique et ça
demande un changement de paradigme est
en fait ces techniques devraient être
soutenus financièrement et techniquement
pour que les maraîchers puissent
s'inscrire dans ce cercle vertueux parce
que c'est très très positif depuis des
dizaines d'années certains maraîchers
font ça et les résultats sont tout
simplement époustouflant plein d'autres
techniques sont envisageables pour les
grandes les petites exploitations pour
les jardins familiaux les jardins de
ville vous avez la permaculture copier
l'exemple de la nature l appliquer à
notre propre vie c'est plus un art de
vivre qu'une technique agricole même si
ça a été quand même beaucoup dénaturer
ces derniers temps on en entend parler à
tort et à travers mais à la base c'est
vraiment une technique très intéressante
vous avez les micro-organismes et
efficace qui vont aider à dépolluer les
sols et à rendre la décomposition de la
matière organique plus efficace enfin
vous avez tout un tas de techniques on a
les outils pour développer une nouvelle
agriculture
il suffit de le vouloir il suffit de
pousser ses issues de secours aide et de
sortir vers la nature en fait tout
simplement ce que j'ai envie de vous
dire là vous voyez mon fils en train de
jeter des graines il a huit ans et j'ai
envie qu'il est un futur j'ai envie que
ce que je voulais c'est plus qu'une
terre empoisonné et je pense que tous
ici on a envie de vivre
on a profondément envie de vivre et si
on veut vivre avec tout l'espoir et
l'avenir que ce mot fait en tout cas
raisonnée pour moi la solution elle se
résume pour moi dans une petite phrase
que tout le monde connaît on récolte ce
que l'on sème tout simplement
et si on veut vivre il faut semer la vie
il faut semer la vie dans les jardins
dans les champs des paysans dans les
champs des maraîchers dans nos coeurs
dans nos relations
il faut se mettre la vie partout et
quand en face les grands coquins comme
j'aime les appelait les criminels
viendront nous enterrer une fois de plus
rappelons nous tout ce que nous sommes
des graines et qu'ensemble à la première
pluie on germera pour créer ensemble un
nouveau paradigme basé sur la corruption
avec la terre basé sur la collaboration
avec notre mère nourricière
merci
[Applaudissements]